Here are our answers. Equation e, would shift our graph up by 6 units, that's
why we have a plus 6 outside the original function. And if you want to shift
down instead, you need to subtract. In this case, we're subtracting by 1 with
equation d. Equation c, which of the graph left by five units since we're
adding to x. And graph a would do essentially the opposite, it would shift the
graph right, this time, by four units. Finally, graph b here, f of x equals
negative x squared, represents that reflection in the x-axis of the original
graph. This negative sign out in front of the original function takes all of
the function values of the original graph and flips them across the x-axis,
makes them negative.